[Music]
alright we're on our way over this is
the real deal yet not [ __ ] around look
how great this guy's much
so I'm on my HD makeup huh gonna look
six months younger [ __ ] am I gonna talk
about brexit huh princess die yes still
dead
great brilliant murdered run off the
road then I make fun of Michelle Obama I
don't get along with you that well Oh
after that [ __ ] there's not good
questions to be asking I love the
cameras I can't see the cameras no
camera is moving nothing swooping in
nothing's hanging from a ceiling no [ __ ]
admission impossible angles bomb [ __ ]
jokes state on the other watch me eat
the string
they're saying on that no they'll be
there will be some English back on
you're supposed to take me [ __ ]
American yeah well your teeth bad plant
kindest plant kindness and gather love
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Kevin it's poor bastard had to spend
nine hours paid my giant head and then
what's funny is like it's like
then you got to try to get my hands to
match the [ __ ] head
it's just you know red head to the worst
where the [ __ ] words goes there we go
yes see that I practice what I preach in
my accent like that look at it almost 51
years old
now these [ __ ] idiots getting Botox
and all that [ __ ] you just the emotion
[Music]